they're the swift silent symbols of
Wimbledon sharing the spotlight with the
Stars but obliged to blend into the
background but the honor of becoming a
ball boy or girl at one of the world's
biggest tennis tournaments isn't won
easily from initial applications 700
make it through to the selection process
and after months of training just over a
third make the grid every drill every
move is performed under watchful eyes
none more keen than those of the woman
who's been choosing her young protege
for over a quarter of a century
it is quite ruthless if they don't go
with our rules they don't last for a
start
some of them actually look all boys and
girls just from the way they stand I
think it's sometimes a gut instinct as
they walk through the door there's
something about them that you instantly
recognize I think it's just when you've
done it for so many years you just
somehow pick it up as well as general
fitness the ball boys and girls need to
know the game inside out and read the
players every move most difficult of all
though is simply standing still for
quite some time no easy task for
energetic teenagers
after repeating these drills week in
week out for five months it's hardly
surprising just how badly they want to
qualify for Wimbledon so desperately
once I thought I got out and I was so
upset yeah I just really want to be
there cause after you've done five
months of training you know you don't
want that to be wasted I'd be upset
because some of my friends didn't get
through and they they're quite unhappy
about it yeah just have to try your best
and also you could do you for those
who've lasted the distance the real work
begins on Monday over the next fortnight
half a million fans will be watching on
court with millions more chilling in
around the world and Wimbledon everyone
has to be in peak condition even if
they're only children audition are we
Sky News